what's up with all the different
lightsabers luckily for you we know
which colors are used by which kind of
folks what they say about the weirdest
personality and the whether or not a
yellow lightsaber makes sense for you
here's the true meaning behind each
lightsaber color the blue lightsaber is
a classic for a reason it's the iconic
first lightsaber seen being activated on
screen in a new home and since both
Anakin Skywalker and obi-wan Kenobi had
won it seems like the standard issue for
the Jedi Knights back in the day a long
time before a long time ago
it was established that a blue
lightsaber meant the user was a Jedi
Guardian the samurai of the Jedi Order
with their training focus on outer space
martial arts and lightsaber tomfoolery
guardians were roar monks whose arrival
heralded a hasty round of limb removal
especially if they had the higher ground
so what does this mean about the person
behind the lightsaber mainly that they
could be a little more of a soldier than
your average Jedi with the blue saber
functioning as a uniform a green
lightsaber was a calling card of the
Jedi counselors a thinking sentience
Jedi we all did in the films by folks
like qui-gon jinn the wise Master Yoda
and an older and more self-assured Luke
Skywalker green lightsaber crystals seem
to indicate maturity and thoughtfulness
or at least as thoughtful as you can be
while using them primarily to cut off
people's hands anyway typically Jedi
counselors were especially force
sensitive and they weren't generally
down for a fight in the same way that a
Jedi Guardian might be they were
diplomats scholars ambassadors and
teachers focusing on their studies and
such a lot of space meditation wisdom
was their deal as for the real-world
reason well it's not quite us for the
Safa call the first green lightsaber the
fan sword said of the Jedi was
originally blue but the filmmakers
realized that it was blending in with
the sky too much during the outdoor
action sequences if you see a red
lightsaber firing up in a dark alley a
speedy bar or god forbid a smoke-filled
Carbonite freezing chamber on Bespin
then buddy that's bad news the red saber
crystal is a hallmark of the Sith
than a Farias bad guys of the Star Wars
Canon the distinctive red glow of a Sith
lightsaber
comes from a particularly nasty
construction process that involves its
wielder pouring all of their negative
emotions into a synthetic crystal of
course a rough start in life doesn't
always mean that a crystal is doomed for
good
to get a shot at our rebranding a little
ways down the road purple it's the
universal sign of a hardcore dude for a
seats please see Prince Thanos grimace
and mates window and then a Star Wars
universe
a purple lightsaber represents a user's
connection to both the light and dark
side of the force
we ordered only by the most bold and
daring Jedi possibly Odin in the real
world which is occasionally even more
fun than the one with Jabba the Hutt in
it purple lightsabers exist because
samuel l.jackson really wanted one since
he was going to be in a scene with
dozens of other saber wielding jedi he
wanted to be able to cloak himself on
the big screen and that's Lucas to give
him a more distinctive weapon bold and
daring indeed he may not have seen a
yellow lightsaber in the movies but come
on this is Star Wars and we all know how
expanded that universe can get a yellow
lightsaber was a preferred weapon of the
Jedi Sentinel their pragmatic force
users who skipped out on meditation and
communing with the universe in favor of
developing more practical skills they
were also frequently assigned to scars
of the Jedi Temple
sporting two-sided lightsaber pipes with
distinctive amber blades for these
guides sabers were like a traffic light
you see yellow you better slow down even
in the impossibly long list of
characters and the extended free Disney
star wars universe there were only a few
waving around orange lightsabers the
most famous example was probably a doll
the female member of Yoda species he was
barely seen in the Phantom Menace and
then relegated to the pages of
officially licensed books and comics
it's been speculated that orange sabers
were only owned by Jedi who swore not to
use their weapons unless absolutely
necessary and maybe that's why we never
saw them in the movies rare even by
fictional weapon standards the white
lightsaber borders are unique in the
current Canon these bright blades
belonged to ahsoka tano Anakin's old
Padawan it's a long story but a soko
wound up being one of the few characters
to leave the Jedi Order that ultimi D
Utley going to the dark side when she
threw down with a sit affiliated Jedi
hunter she'd NAB's the red crystals out
of his lightsaber and cleanse them with
the power of the force turning them a
brilliant but decidedly neutral white
for the Jedi who once a weapon that goes
of everything there's a black lightsaber
it's one of a kind
at least until the Star Wars writers
change their mind in a couple of years
the dark saber
isn't just her everyday Jedi weapon it
was a sabre of want our villa the first
Mandalorian Jedi Mandalorians were
pretty famous during the Old Republic
time period for their enthusiasm about
murdering Jedi so a black lightsaber was
pretty fitting the dark saber wound up
being handed down from warrior to
warrior throughout the millennia
eventually being used in battles with
all of the usual suspects Obi Wan Darth
Maul and even Emperor Palpatine
according to the Mandalorians the only
way to legitimately claim the blade for
yourself was to kill the person who had
it before you making the weapons history
a long list of bad times and badder
people these colors represent the light
sabers that currently exists in the
official Star Wars continuity but they
don't even scratched the surface of what
fans have seen in the expanded universe
of Star Wars legends books games and
comics to the surprise of absolutely
nobody it seems like just about every
creative minds task was telling a Star
Wars story over the last 40 odd years
has come up with their own distinctive
look for a lightsaber fans have listed
nearly a hundred different documented
lightsaber colors from the slightly
different to the downright bizarre lo
Bukka one of the few wookie Jedi had a
bronze-colored blade for example really
just about any color you can imagine
with the tragic exception of Paige is
yours for the claiming once you start
bound the Jedi path check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the BAL so you don't miss
a single one